une atmosphère des grands soirs ce
samedi 3 février au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines plus de 4000
spectateurs se sont rassemblés dans
l'enceinte pour assister au match de
coupe d'europe e h f
entre les joueuses d'ici paris les
norvégiennes de christiane c'est
justement ça permet aussi de faire
découvrir aux enfants mâles ambiance de
match et puis à des joutes européennes
c'est toujours particulier parmi une
cinquantaine de norvégiens avaient fait
le déplacement pour ce choc européen
comptant pour la 5e journée de la phase
de groupes
je ne sais pas si on va gagner je pense
que c'est un match difficile je suis un
peu effrayé l'issue de la rencontre
mais j'ai l'espoir qu'on puisse le faire
un espoir récompenser les vipères ce
christiane 100 s'impose d'un but dans
les dernières minutes contre les
franciliennes score final 25 à 24 ici
paris menez pour tous le 3 buts à la mi
temps
l'ambiance du vélodrome n'a pas réussi à
empêcher la remonte haddad et
norvégienne et c'est des matchs avec des
joueuses très expérimentées
une bonne partie du jeu se démarque par
sa sont une équipe de norvège dont la
gardienne
l'arrière gauche la demi centre est
ouais nous a pas beaucoup réussi cette
année mais bon c'est pas grave on va
c'est gagner le prochain match de coupe
d'europe
il y avait une super ambiance l'année
dernière nous avions gagné contre brest
ce match là était très serré et nous
avons une nouvelle fois bien joué ici et
peut-être l'année prochaine encore les
joueuses d'ici paris se déplaceront sur
le terrain des russes de la da pour la
6e et dernière journée de phase de
poules de coupe d'europe en cas de
qualification les lionnes pourrait
revenir pour un nouveau match européen
au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines dans les
prochaines semaines